[Musik]
quarantäne ausgangssperre soziale
distanzierung ein fast vollständiger
wirtschaftlicher stillstand und viel
viel unsicherheit darüber was als
nächstes kommen könnte die korona krise
erschüttert die ganzen welt aber zwei
länder italien und spanien scheint
besonders hart von ihr getroffen zu
sagen da ein teil der redaktion von
visual politik direkt in madrid
angesiedelt ist können wir euch eingehen
und aus erster hand über den stand der
dinge in spanien aufklären sowie über
alle wichtigen hintergründe durch die
erst verstehen werdet wie es gerade in
spanien hat der dramatischen situation
kommen die menschen in spanien wurden
von der krise in einer weise erschüttert
die noch vor wenigen monaten die ein
hollywood streifen angebot hätte wie ein
waschechter katastrophen schinken von
roland emmerich und das schlimmste ist
dass noch einige schwierige wochen vor
uns liegen und viele menschliche
tragödien wohin man nur schaut praktisch
alle geschäfte mit ausnahme von
supermärkten apotheken und anderen
geschäften für lebenswichtige güter
mussten schließen zum beispiel alle bars
restaurants bekleidungsgeschäfte und
einkaufszentren
[Musik]
und natürlich ist nicht nur der
einzelhandel betroffen alle unternehmen
ist auf die systemrelevanten wurden
ebenfalls gezwungen den betrieb
einzustellen
die spanische regierung genannte diesen
einmaligen vorgang euphemistisch
winterschlaf dies hat dazu geführt dass
abertausende jahr hunderttausende von
spanien schon jetzt arbeitslos geworden
sind oder auch mit erheblichen
einkommenseinbußen verbundene kurzarbeit
gesetzt wurden
[Musik]
von den arbeitsplatzverlusten sind
bereits 15 millionen arbeitnehmer
betroffen
es bleibt nichts anderes übrig als zu
hoffen dass viele dieser menschen ihren
arbeitsplatz zurück bekommen sobald
diese krise ausgestanden ist aber für
viele andere wird dieser zusammenbruch
wahrscheinlich den endgültigen verlust
ihrer arbeitsplätze bedeuten die
unsicherheit darüber wie die zukunft
aussehen wird könnte nicht grösser
denn noch nie zuvor hat jemand diesen
mächtigen schalter betätigt in schalter
mit denen das gesamte soziale und
wirtschaftliche leben eines landes auf
einmal ausgeknipst wird selbst im
kriegsfall geschieht so etwas nicht denn
dann wird die produktion eben auf
kriegswirtschaft umgestellt nicht jedoch
auf 0
[Musik]
die produktionsaktivität sinkt aufgrund
von unsicherheit und geringen
bestellungen um 66 prozent
labbadia wie war das alles möglich wir
sind wir bis zu diesem punkt bekommen
nun zum einen lag dies daran dass
während asiatische länder anfang februar
bereits sehr aktiv gegen die solche
kämpften in westlichen ländern bis
praktisch weit in den märz hinein
einfach gar nichts unternommen wurde
keinerlei vorbereitungsmaßnahmen nichts
und plötzlich panik regenmäntel
taucherbrillen und durch kappen die
erste in madrid sind am ende die
verzweiflung beginnt für das gesamte
medizinische personal spürbar zu werden
aus müllsäcken bastelt man sich auf die
schnelle schutzkleidung um den mangel in
krankenhäusern auszugleichen die
versprochenen lieferungen kommen nicht
an elcon finanziell in diesem video
erklären wir euch was alles bei angetan
und unterlassen hat damit sich die
korona krise auf die schlimmste aller
erdenklichen weisen auswirken konnte es
ist eine geschichte von
opportunistischen politikern und
verantwortlichen medien ignoranz und
halbwahrheiten
mit dem falschen fuß aufgestanden
das jahr 2020 versprach ein gutes jahr
zu werden
die märkte schienen nach vielen höhen
und tiefen drohen und handelskriegen
optimistisch zu sagen die
arbeitslosigkeit in den vereinigten
staaten war auf einem historischen
tiefstand
und auch in spanien gegen die
arbeitslosigkeit immer weiter zurück
während die prognosen für das
wirtschaftswachstum recht positiver am
ersten januar 2020 konnte sich noch
niemand vorstellen was für ein
schreckliches jahr uns bevorsteht im
januar desselben jahres gab es in china
jedoch bereits hunderte von bestätigten
infektionen mit gewittern sind die
dunkelziffer lag damals vermutlich schon
in den tausenden
gerade deshalb muss das chinesische
regime schließlich zugeben dass eine
epidemie im gange war und drastische
maßnahmen dagegen ergreifen wie zum
beispiel die absolute quarantäne der
gesamten provinz hubei einer provinz mit
etwa 60 millionen einwohnern
im rest chinas wurde ebenfalls maßnahmen
zur sozialen distanzierung
ausgangssperren und schließungen von
geschäften und fabriken ergriffen
das bringt der welt standen die
fließbänder still die
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu rief am
31 erst 2020 den globalen
gesundheitsnotstand aus 31 erster 2020
corona virus von der whu zum globalen
gesundheitsnotstand erklärt wie sie was
man hier wäre es da nicht langsam an der
zeit gewesen dass länder wie italien und
spanien wenigstens ein paar minimale
vorbereitungen treffen wie so gut weil
genau diese länder sowieso fast jedes
jahr während der grippesaison die
erfahrung machen dass die krankenhäuser
im chaos versinkt und warum befinden
sich die maroden gesundheitssysteme
dieser beiden länder während der krippe
so am rande des zusammenbruchs
das ist kein großes geheimnis denn
obwohl das durchschnittsalter der
dortige bevölkerung und damit die zahl
der alten patienten jedes jahr immer
weiter steigt und weit über dem
europäischen durchschnitt liegt während
die dortigen krankenhäuser seit jahren
systematisch kaputtgespart
[Musik]
darüber hinaus gehen die erste in
spanien oder italien schon seit vielen
jahren wesentlich großzügiger beim
einsatz mit antibiotika um als dies in
fast allen anderen ländern europas der
fall ist nein die zurückhaltung beim
verschreiben von antibiotika wie sie von
ersten in anderen ländern praktiziert
wird damit möglichst wenig
antibiotikaresistente keime
herangezüchtet werden gehört dort
einfach nicht zur üblichen praxis auch
jeden gleißende schnupfen einfach für
den fall der fälle wird auch sofort mit
einer batterie von antibiotika gefeiert
und so sind es dann vor allem
krankenhäuser in spanien und italien die
unvergleichlich stark mit
multiresistenten keimen verseucht sind
gegen die gar keine antibiotika melden
wie gesagt das alles ist seit vielen
jahren bekannt es gibt dazu unzählige
studien und natürlich wissen auch die
spanischen gesundheitsbehörden seit
jahren dass sie aufgrund genau dieser
problematik jedes jahr starten engpässen
im gesundheitssystem rechnen müssen und
eigentlich verdammt auf der hut sein
sollten wenn eine epidemie droht und
deswegen taten sich als der kogit 19
tsunami auf spaniens wollte genau gar
nichts und wieso nun scheinbar hätte es
dem stolz der spanier verletzt zuzugeben
die nächst die dinge wirklich stehen
dass sie nicht das beste alle
gesundheitssysteme haben und dass die
spanische bevölkerung nicht gerade die
gesündeste ist ein parteioberen der
rechts nationalistischen partei vox
versuchte sogar bei seinen wählern mit
einer kruden thesen punkte dass die
stolzen spanischen antikörper die
verdammten chinesischen viren mit
leichtigkeit besiegen könnten
unglaublich nicht war aber wartet es
wird noch viel besser denn es sieht ganz
danach aus dass von dieser ihre
nationalistischen vision auch das
sozialistische gesundheitsminister
salvador ihr getriebe als auch sein
oberster epidemie koordinator fernando
simon und diese einstellung änderte sich
selbst an nicht als da wären tsunami aus
china nicht mehr viele tausend kilometer
entfernt wütete seien praktisch gleich
um die ecke in italien
[Musik]
bis zum 29 februar zählte italien
bereits mehr als 1000 fälle von covidien
infektionen und nur eine woche später
schon mehr als 5000 fälle
trotzdem war die spanische regierung
weiterhin die ruhe selbst und das obwohl
spanien oder italien sehr eng
miteinander verbunden sind sich als
weltoffene tourismus länder historisch
kulturell sprachlich und wirtschaftlich
sehr nahe stehen
selbst als die erste kurve 19
infektionen auf spanischem boden
angekommen war hielt man es nicht für
notwendig kontrollen an flughäfen
einzurichten noch züge busse oder
bahnhöfe zu desinfizieren noch
wenigstens medizinisches material ohne
schutzkleidung zu beschaffen und das
obwohl länder wie zb südkorea
erfolgreich vorgemacht haben dass man
mit solchen maßnahmen die solche unter
kontrolle bekommen kann
über das positive beispiel südkorea und
wie man dort das thema virus durch eine
reihe intelligenter maßnahmen eindämmen
konnte übrigens ohne drastischen
lockdown und landesweiter quarantäne
haben wir schon vor zwei wochen ein
video gedreht das ihr euch ansehen
können indem wir jetzt auf den
eingeblendeten link oben klickt oder
später auf den in der beschreibung zu
diesem video nun leider hat sich wohl
niemand in der spanischen regierung
unser video angesehen und wir wissen
wirklich nicht was man sich dort
stattdessen reingezogen hat denn
eigentlich hatten sie genau das
gegenteil dessen was umgebracht werden
der achte märz 2020 wird in spanien als
das datum in die geschichte eingehen an
dem die spanische regierung die
bevölkerung des landes den corona virus
quasi zum fraß vorwerfen denn obwohl die
behörden genau wussten dass sich das
virus bereits im land frei ausbreitete
war die spanische regierung fest
entschlossen die damit einhergehenden
probleme herunterzuspielen wie es nur
ging denn auf gar keinen fall sollten
schlechte nachrichten und hässliche
bilder die demonstrationen und
feierlichkeiten zum internationalen
frauentag beeinflussen denn solche
demonstrationen und veranstaltungen sind
in spanien äußerst beliebt und finden
immer in großer zahl und unter reger
beteiligung statt zudem sind sie ideale
gelegenheiten für politiker sich zu
profilieren und somit ein sehr wichtiges
ereignis für die beide
regierungsparteien ps und problem muss
diese tollen polit events wollte sich
die regierung einfach nicht von einem
blöden virus versauen lassen wäre ja
noch schöner gewesen
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles am selben
tag fanden in ganz spanien kundgebungen
konzerte sportveranstaltungen und viele
andere events statt bei denen
abertausende von menschen der solche
ausgesetzt waren allein bei einer
kundgebung der bereits erwähnten vor
stolz nur so strotzenden partei vox
wurden den virus 9000 menschen in madrid
am 8 märz in einem geschlossenen zahl
als hauptspeise serviert
wenige tage später wurde bekannt dass
die hälfte der box parteiführung
infiziert war
und wie es sich ja vorstellen könnt
laufen bei den lebenslustigen spanien
hat diese veranstaltung überaus sozial
und distanziert ab alle umarmen und
drücken sich schütteln sich herzhaft die
hände und geben sich groß und quer
unmengen von küsschen jeder mit jedem
[Musik]
sehr praktisch in einer solchen
situation nicht wahr zumindest für das
virus haben allerliebsten würde ich mir
jetzt facebook mäßig ins gesicht
schlagen aber man so sicher nicht am
gesicht anfassen und nein es gibt keine
entschuldigung für die vorgänge in
spanien denn die whu hatte bereits eine
offizielle warnung gegeben in italien
war bereits die kacke am dampfen und man
wusste dass es in spanien bereits mehr
als 600 positiv diagnostizierte fälle
gab die sozialistische regierung von
pedro sanchez reagierte spät und
ungeschickt dem land fehlte es an
wesentliche ausrüstung beatmungsgeräte
schutzkleidung zu erste und testkits
wurden erst jetzt geschafft children at
spanien korrespondent westen
an dieser stelle sollten wir uns die
frage stellen wie eine regierung nur
dermaßen versagen sollte war hier
einfach alles egal oder handelte es sich
um eine fehlkalkulation diese frage
werden wir nun beantragten passt auf
[Musik]
das vorher und nachher bild eines ganzen
landes
also liebe freunde von visual politik
amerikas und amigos haltet euch fest
denn die spanische regierung versuchte
nicht mal einen tag lang zu verbergen
warum sie die bevölkerung einer
derartigen gefahr aussetzt denn genau am
nächsten tag am 9 märz änderte die
regierung ihre meinung um genau 180 grad
mann erklärte dass corona virus zur
allergrößten gefahr uns hinan dagegen
mit aller macht zu kämpfen was für ein
mieses schmierentheater ich meine nur
damit wir uns richtig verstehen bis zu
800 ermutigte die regierung die menschen
auf die straße zu gehen sich unbegrenzt
zu versammeln und so ausgelassen
miteinander zu feiern als gäbe es kein
morgen nur einen einzigen tag darauf am
9 märz boom den totalen krieg gegen das
corona virus ausgerufen nur einen tag
später einfach umwerfend
die gemeinde madrid verordnet die
schließung aller bildungseinrichtungen
während der nächsten zwei wochen
aber langsam denn diese ersten maßnahmen
wurden noch nicht von der spanischen
zentralregierung angeordnet sondern
durch die autonomen regionalregierung
die übrigens bis zu diesem zeitpunkt
auch praktisch nichts getan haben und
deswegen liefen diese maßnahmen so
unkoordiniert ab wie es nur ging
zwischen den regionalregierungen und der
zentralregierung fand so gut wie keine
kommunikation statt so führte zum
beispiel das fehlen von
reisebeschränkungen nach der schließung
der schulen dazu dass viele lehrer und
studenten aus den großstädten in ihre
herkunft regionen führen und das virus
massenweise dorthin mitnehmen
[Musik]
ein ähnliches desaster spielte sich ab
als der regierungspräsident pedro
sanchez den notstand mehr als 24 stunden
vor seiner umsetzung an kündigt aber an
diesem punkt stellt ihr euch vielleicht
die frage ob der einzige grund warum
dieses chaos in kauf genommen und
schließlich auch verursacht wurde
nur ein paar politische veranstaltungen
und waren die man nicht ausfallen lassen
wollte denn wenn dies der einzige grund
war warum haben dann auch die
regionalregierung nichts unternommen nur
liebe zuschauer nur selten gibt es für
eine solche katastrophe nur eine einzige
ursache und in diesem fall war dies
nicht anders viele verschiedene
interessen spielten hier zusammen und
orchestrierten den perfekten stuhl
[Musik]
spanien ist eine tourismus großmacht es
ist ein mittelmeerland mit viel sonne
und kilometerlangen stränden guten essen
und billigem alkohol ein paradies für
millionen europäischer touristen
tatsächlich in spanien allein im jahr
2009 10 84 millionen touristen aus den
rest der welt 84 millionen touristen in
einem land mit etwas mehr als 45
millionen einwohnern
ihr könnt euch sicher vorstellen wie
wichtig der tourismus für die spanische
wirtschaft ist gesprächen von mehr als
zwölf prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
und zwei millionen arbeitsplätze
[Musik]
und alles deutet darauf hin dass die
tourismus lobby viel damit zu tun hatte
dass einige politiker vor allem
regionalpolitiker ist vollzogen lieber
wegzuschauen man wollte einfach nicht
wahrhaben was auch sparen hinzu kommt es
stand einfach zu viel geld auf dem spiel
aber jetzt wo das kind in den brunnen
gefallen ist stellt sich die frage was
es gekostet hat nicht zu handeln wird
für diese ganze katastrophe jemand
politisch zur verantwortung gezogen
[Musik]
selbstkritik fehlanzeige
nur liebe anlieger sondern niveaus in
dieser ganzen geschichte gab es
eigentlich nur zwei möglichkeiten
entweder man handelt ganz schnell
akzeptiert den ernst der lage und
ergreift von anfang an maßnahmen um die
ausbreitung des virus einzudämmen
oder man tut es eben nicht und findet
sich dann in einer situation wieder in
der spanien zum zeitpunkt der
veröffentlichung dieses normal ist und
man entschied sich dort eben für diese
zweite option obwohl es an warnungen
überhaupt nicht mangelte zwanzigster
januar china bestätigt die ausbreitung
des neuen corona virus von mensch zu
mensch der new york times
rona virus todesfälle übersteigen die
saas todesfälle aus dem jahr 2003 bbc
fünfundzwanzigster februar corona virus
die welt muss sich auf eine pandemie
vorbereitet sagt die whu wie sie nun
diese warnungen hätten der spanischen
regierung eigentlich ausreichen können
um abzuschätzen dass eine
krankheitswelle auf das land zu rollt
insbesondere wenn man bedenkt dass
fernando simon der chefkoordinator des
spanischen gesundheitsministeriums auch
zur führung des europäischen zentrums
für die prävention und die kontrolle von
krankheiten icd sie gehört jedes cd ist
das bereits am 2
eindringlich volle massenveranstaltungen
abrät
[Musik]
ihr habt richtig gehört derselbe mann
der seinen eigenen sohn auf die
massenkundgebung am 8 märz geschickt
hatte
über zur führungsriege der europäischen
institution die sechs tage zuvor von
massenveranstaltungen abgeraten hatte um
die ausbreitung der infektion zu
verhindern und wenn ihr das schon
ziemlich schräg findet was jetzt kommt
entlassung des präventionsrates der
polizei der den plan gegen das corona
virus verfasst hat el mundo
genau je nach verantwortliche bei der
spanischen polizei denn bereits im
januar seine vorgesetzten vor den
gefahren des corona virus gewarnt und
einen plan mit schutzmaßnahmen ins
porsche hatte wurde gefeiert scheinbar
kam diese unschöne wahrheit bei seinen
vorgesetzten nicht besonders gut an
und eine ähnlich opportunistische pferd
fällt wie die politik von führten am 9
märz auch die spanischen medien auch sie
spielten die gefahr der solche zunächst
herunter die missstände im
gesundheitswesen wurden unter den
teppich gekehrt nur um dann von einem
tag auf den anderen plötzlich in den
totale panik modus zu schalten
tja und wozu führte diese hochgradig
intransparente heuchlerische und
sprunghafte kommunikation zur totalen
verunsicherung der bevölkerung einer
bevölkerung welche die gesundheitlichen
herausforderungen einer solche und
mögliche engpässe im maroden
gesundheitssystem zunächst überhaupt
nicht ernst nehmen da sie ja auch ihre
meinungsführer nicht ernst nahmen
plötzlich aufgeschreckt durch die
abrupte hysterie nun jedes kleinste
krankheit symbol beobachtend aus dieser
angst heraus massenhaft in die
krankenhäuser zu stürmen in genau jene
mit multiresistenten keimen verseuchten
krankenhäuser für die spanien so berühmt
ist diese krankenhäuser waren natürlich
vollkommen unvorbereitet und hatten
keinerlei medizinische hilfsmittel wie
zum beispiel schnell test oder
schutzkleidung hektisch kaufte die
spanische regierung jetzt in einer nacht
und nebelaktion hunderttausende
minderwertiger corona testkits von einer
chinesischen firma auch schön sein
welche noch nicht einmal von der
chinesischen regierung zertifiziert
waren diese tests erwiesen sich als
total fehleranfällig und unbrauchbar
[Musik]
jeder behauptet dass spanien die
fehlgeschlagenen tests von einem nicht
lizensierten hersteller gekauft habt die
chinesische botschaft in spanien
behauptet dass die fehlerhaften testkits
die spanien gekauft hat von einer firma
stammen die nicht auf der offiziellen
verkäufer liste der chinesischen
regierung stand l kontinent
kurz gesagt all diese desaströsen dinge
zusammen genommen haben dazu geführt
dass die korona welle zu einem
zusammenbruch des spanischen
gesundheitssystems geführt hat ich
glaube dass wir an diesem punkt die
unterschiede zu jenen ländern in denen
es gelungen ist den schaden durch das
virus und die zahl der todesfälle in
akzeptablen grenzen zu halten
ich zum beispiel südkorea oder taiwan
besser verstehen können realistisches
risikomanagement transparente
krisenkommunikation und ein gut
aufgestelltes gesundheitssystem auf der
einen seite und politischer
opportunismus sparrate panikmache und
verunsicherung totales missmanagement
auf der anderen die ergebnisse sprechen
für sich
und was denkt ihr glaubt ihr dass euer
land mit der situation richtig umgeht
oder ähnliche fehler wegen spanien macht
wir sind auf eure sachlich fundierten
kommentare die immer äußerst gespannt
falls euch dieses video gefallen hat
geht uns bitte einen daumen hoch
abonniert unseren kanal und klickt auch
auf das glöckchen damit er
benachrichtigt werden wenn ein neues
ressort politik video erscheint macht's
gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]